we are ready to hear from our keynote
speaker and so we'll delay uh the ballot
uh report until uh after uh that is
completed it is my deep pleasure to
introduce to you Robert Spencer uh who
is known by many himself a a mikit mikit
Catholic studied Islamic theology law
and history since
1980 Robert Spencer got his Masters in
religious studies at the University of
North Carolina he's an adjunct fellow
with the free uh Congress foundation in
2002 and 2003 wrote as a a series of
monographs on Islam he's written many
other monographs for the David Horwitz
Freedom Center as well he's known as
America's most informed fearless and
compelling voice on Modern uh
jihadism one of the most significant and
insightful learned Scholars of Islam
he's armed with facts and fearlessly
stands up for Western
Civilization Spencer has led seminars on
Islam and Jihad for the United States
Central Command United States Army
command the FBI The Joint terrorism task
force the US intelligence community and
many
more he is Vice President of the freedom
Defense Initiative and director of jihad
watch a program of the David Horwitz
Center he has written 13 books he's
completed a weekly commentary on the
Corran Quan uh at bloging the Quran that
has been translated into six different
languages and we also uh have read some
of his works as well they're deeply
inspired by his
honesty uh and the Integrity of his
voice in his book the political correct
incorrect guide to Islam he writes
that's why I have placed a Muhammad
versus Jesus sidebar in every chapter to
emphasize the fallacy of those who claim
that Islam and Christianity are
basically equal in their ability to
inspire good or evil furthermore through
the words of Muhammad and Jesus we can
draw a distinction between core
principles that guide the faithful
Muslim and
Christian in his book religion of Peace
Spencer writes Western civilizations
rooted as it is in the judeo-christian
tradition is a profoundly different one
from the model of society dictated by
Islamic Sharia law
in another book The Truth About Muhammad
Spencer
writes that he relies exclusively on
Islamic sources to argue the words and
deeds of Muhammad having been moving
Muslims to commit the acts of violence
over 1,400
years we give thanks to God that he is
able to be with us and I would like you
to join me in welcoming Robert Spencer
[Applause]
thank
you thank you very much Bishop John and
thank you all for inviting me here it's
a great honor for me to be able to
address you today on such an topic of
importance uh we see practically every
day horrific new stories about the
persecution of Christians in uh the
Middle East and elsewhere in the Islamic
world and I thought that today it would
be useful in order to help you to
understand why this is all happening to
uh take you through the Islamic view of
Christians and Christianity as per the
Islamic holy book the Quran I know that
you had a Bible study earlier and so I
thought it would be a good time to have
a little Quran study and so uh I know
you all have yours if you'd open your
qurans to uh 5:
46 uh you'll see that the Quran actually
says something that is often cited
by spokesmen who are hastening to tell
us that there really isn't any problem
and that ultimately there is a great
welcoming Spirit within Islam for
Christians and Christianity and uh 5:46
it says and we sent Jesus the son of
Mary after those prophets confirming the
truth of whatever there still remained
of the Torah and we gave him the gospel
wherein is guidance and
light wherein is guidance and light in
the gospel and so you would think this
is a very generous ecumenical statement
that the gospel contains guidance and
light and so a Christian can look at
that and say well this is great this is
a a holy book of another religion that
in a rather unprecedented and unusual
manner is recognizing the truth of the
holy book of a different
religion but there's
more very shortly after that passage we
can go to chapter 5: 65 and just in case
you don't have your Quran I'll read it
for you uh had the people of the book
that's the quran's term primarily for
Jews and Christians had the people of
the book only believed and been
God-fearing we surely we being God
surely would have effaced from them
their evil deeds and caused them to
enter The Gardens of bliss okay so what
it is what is it that the people of the
book that is the the Jews and the
Christians had to do in order to enter
The Gardens of bliss had the people of
the book it goes on observed the Torah
and the
gospel and all that had been revealed to
them from their lord sustenance would
have been showered over them from above
and would have risen from beneath their
feet some among them in certainly keep
to the right path but many of them do
things that are evil so now we have two
groups of Christians some that are on
the right path and some that do evil and
If Only They had kept to if had the
people of the book observed the Torah
and the gospel then everything would
have been okay so it seems as if there's
some of these people of the book some of
the Christians who don't observe what's
in the
gospel and they are obviously the ones
on the wrong path but what is actually
what has actually gone wrong in their
way of thinking according to the
Quran in chapter 5:1 17 and 72 it
repeats it twice the statement that
unbelievers are those who say Allah is
the Messiah the Son of Mary that is
those who affirm the Divinity of Christ
those who say that Allah or God is
Christ or that Christ is God then they
are
unbelievers and so in one Fell Swoop in
those two passages that passage that is
actually affirmed twice the Quran is
actually saying that the faith of all
virtually all Christians throughout
history Protestants Catholics Orthodox
that Jesus Christ is the Divine Son of
God God the son the second person of the
Trinity is a manifestation of unb
belief and of course there's more
besides in chap 4: 171 it says they did
not kill or crucify him but it appeared
so unto them in other words they thought
they were crucifying him but they
weren't really which of course takes
away the cross the Resurrection The
Salvation of Christ the sacrificial
death the atonement the whole heart of
Christianity is gone many many other
passages in the Quran
affirm very strongly that it is against
the Transcendent Majesty of God to say
that he would have a son that for him to
have a son would be to imply some
insufficiency on his part that is the
Assumption I don't think that that's
really a true statement regarding
fatherhood on a human level or when
we're talking about the Divinity but
nonetheless this is what is
affirmed so you have I think I said the
wrong number I'm sorry 4157 is about the
crucifixion if you're taking not notes
but what we have in all this and in so
many other passages such as 5: 116 when
Allah actually questions Jesus about
what he taught says in the in the
Hereafter Allah will say Jesus Son of
Mary Did you say to people take me and
my mother as Gods besides Allah this is
the quran's understanding of the Trinity
not the father and the Son and the Holy
Spirit but uh God Jesus and Mary and God
asks him Allah asks him did you tell
your followers to worship you and your
mother as Gods along with me and Jesus
answers glory to you it was not for me
to say what I had no right to say if I
had said so you would have known it you
know all that is within my mind whereas
I do not know what is within yours
obviously then Jesus is not God and is
not part of the
godhead
so we have here obviously
a some very serious theological
disagreements between Islam and all
sects and schools of thought within
Christianity that are mainstream and
have been throughout
history however all that amounts to so
far is just essentially that a
theological disagreement of which there
are many of course and Christians of
course have theological disagreements
among themselves and so this in itself
would not account for the persecution by
itself the problem of course is that in
the Islamic context there is a great
deal more to it besides that when you
have theological disagreements then they
take on a very different character when
combined with the Islamic view that the
Muslims are the executors of the will of
Allah and this is a very important point
in in in the scriptures we hear
vengeance is mine says the Lord I will
repay and Christians are not to take
revenge not to avenge themselves in any
way according to the scriptures in the
Quran you have exactly the opposite
teaching as a matter of fact you have
the
explicit obligation given to Muslims to
be the executors of God's Wrath on Earth
in chapter 9: 74 it says speaking about
unbelievers they are spiteful against
Muslims for no other reason than that
Allah and his Messengers have enriched
them through his Bounty so if they
repent it will be for their own good but
if they turn away Allah will sternly
punish them in this world and in the
Hereafter so in other words the
unbelievers will not only be going to
hell but will be punished in this world
and how will God punish the unbelievers
In This World by means of the
Muslims in chapter
9:14 it
says make war on them Allah will
chastise them through you Allah will
chastise them through you that God in
other words in the Islamic scheme of
things will use the Believers the Muslim
Believers to punish those who deviate
from creedal orthodox
oxy he will chastise them through
you so this creates you see an
obligation for a Pious and knowledgeable
Muslim and understands it to be the
perfect word of God that existed forever
with God in paradise and then was
delivered in perfect form to
Muhammad and has been preserved
throughout the ages down to our present
day this creates in such a person a
feeling that he has a responsibility
before God to fight against those who
have rejected the faith who have as the
Christians have deviated from the truth
that the of the
Gospel they have to be punished in this
world and in the next and done and the
Muslims have to do the
punishing you see in the Islamic scheme
of things Jesus was a Muslim Prophet who
taught Islam
then the gospel was guidance and light
but afterward his followers came along
and they twisted and hijacked the
original perfect teachings of Jesus that
corresponded exactly with the teachings
of Muhammad who would come later and
they changed them into something in
which Jesus dies on a cross and is the
Son of God and part of the
Trinity thus outraging the truth of the
message of Christ and placing them into
the camp of the
unbelievers who have to then be punished
by the hand of God working through his
true
believers so when we see this
persecution in the Middle East when we
see the Islamic State or Isis as it's
popularly known Waging War against the
Christians driving them out of lands
that they have lived in for
centuries the people who were doing that
believe that they are carrying out a
Divine responsibility something that
will bring them blessings from
God you may recall that Jesus himself
said in the Gospel of John the time will
come when men will kill you and think
they're offering service to God that
time is upon us
now the time will come when men will
kill you and think they're offering
service to God that is happening every
day in Iraq in Syria and elsewhere now
there's one obvious objection that may
be in your minds at this point point and
that is this that the Christians who
were for example driven out of
mosul the caldan Catholic Archbishop of
mosul a very large and important city in
Iraq and a city that's had a Christian
presence since the beginning of
Christianity the C caldan Catholic
Archbishop of mosul said a few months
ago he said my entire
dasis my entire dasis has been lost to
Islam and the same thing will happen to
the Christians in Europe and the United
States if they don't wake up to what's
happening now the objection is this the
entire dasis of which the Archbishop of
mosul was speaking was under Islamic
rule for almost 1400 years and so why is
it only now that the Christians have
been so violently persecuted and driven
out why is it that 15 years ago there
was a Christian population of well over
a million in Iraq and now they have
almost all
gone and there only a few maybe a couple
hundred thousand if that left in the
country and more leaving all the time
why is this happening now if this is all
about the Quran if this is all about
Islamic ideas of being executing the
wrath of Allah against the unbelievers
then how is it that Muslims and
Christians lived in relative peace and
Harmony in Iraq for all those
centuries well that has to do with once
again the Quran and other aspects of
Islamic theology the Quran in chap
9:29 it says fight against those who do
not obey Allah and his messenger and do
not forbid what he has
forbidden even if they are of the people
of the book remember that's the Jews and
Christians
mainly until they pay the gizia with
willing submission and feel themselves
subdued jiz as a tax and so the
Christians have to be fought against
until they pay a tax and are subdued
subjugated under the rule of
Islam once they do that once they
submit then they're allowed essentially
to live in peace this is Islamic
law the submission however comes on the
basis of an institutionalized
discrimination a second class status
that is very carefully detailed in
Islamic law the demies the protected
people they're called or the DI zumies
they are not allowed to hold authority
over Muslims so they only have the most
menial jobs in society and you can even
see to this day in Pakistan the
colloquial term the slang name for
Christians in the society is street
sweepers and you some I sometimes come
across news stories where a Muslim is
saying these sweepers they were they
were being insolent and and they're
called street sweepers because that's
the kinds of jobs they can get they
can't get a job where they hold
authority over a Muslim that would be
contrary to Islamic law Christians in
the is under the rule of Islamic law who
have been subjugated as per that Quran
verse also cannot build new churches or
repair old ones so their communities are
always in a Perpetual state of decline
they cannot uh hold they
cannot not only can they not build new
churches or repair old ones but they can
you have men can I always I I'm sorry
I'm stopping here cuz I always I always
say misstate this and I want to be
careful to say it properly Muslim
women cannot marry non-muslim men but
Muslim men can marry non-muslim women
and you sometimes hear Islamic
apologists in the west say uh you
see Islam is very ecumenical and
generous because Muslim men can marry
non-muslim women and they don't have to
convert isn't that wonderful
well that might be wonderful but the
reality is that it's another
supremacist manifestation that Muslim
men can marry non-muslim women but
Muslim women cannot marry non-muslim men
the idea is of course the woman goes
into the man's household and the Muslim
Community is always growing whereas the
non-muslim community is always declining
it's the same impulse as behind the law
that mandates that mus Christians can't
build new churches or repair old ones so
you have various other regulations in
some cases throughout history the uh
Christians and the Jews were forbidden
to wear shoes to ride horses they had to
like in the old Jim Crow laws in the Old
South the non-muslims had to step off
the street and let the Muslims pass if
the Muslims were coming and so on all of
this is designed to remind the
Christians that they have re rebelled
against the true God and that they have
strayed from the right path and that
they are suffering in this world as well
as the next because of their rejection
of Muhammad and the Quran and
Islam but once you're in those
boundaries once you have accepted the
subjugated status the second class
status and you know that your life hangs
on the whim of the overlords and you
accept the denial of basic rights that
the dimma entails then you can
live and so the Christians who lived in
mosul for centuries under the Islamic
caliphates going back to the 7th
Century they lived in peace as long as
they knew their
place if they got out of line they would
be
killed and there were various periods of
relaxation just as there are in any
society under any legal system times
when it's enforced very rigorously in
times when it's not enforced so
rigorously and so there were times when
the Christians were able to even in a
relative sense Prosper particularly in
the decline of the last caliphate the uh
the C the caleff is the successor of
Muhammad as the spiritual military and
political leader of the Muslims and the
kaith was the the caliphates ruled over
much of Islam the Islamic world all the
way through history up until 1924 when
the last calate was abolished by the
secular Turkish government but the last
caliphate the Ottoman Empire
you may know if you studied history was
referred to as the sick men of Europe in
the late 19th century and the early 20th
century because it was in such a
drastically weakened State and in that
period the Western Powers at a time when
the West was much more confident about
its own principles than it is today
actually pressured the Ottomans to relax
some of these restrictions on the
Christians and to abolish some of these
laws that had mandated their second
class status and the last of them were
abolished in the year 1856 and so after
1856 in the Middle East and particularly
in Iraq which was an ottoman Province
you had Christians living in relative
peace General peace and general almost
equality with the Muslims it's never
been legal in any Muslim country even
secular turkey for Christians to prze
and try to convert Muslims but otherwise
they really were living in a uh state of
almost equality
now that brings us into modern times and
then by the time you have Saddam Hussein
there and the Iraq war that toppled him
you have various Islamic groups both
Sunni and Shiite that wanted to restore
the rule of Islamic law wanted to
restore es especially the subjugated
status of the Christians the dimma the
second class status mandated in the
Quran remember in chapter 9: 29 where it
says that the Christians must pay the
gizia the tax with willing submission
and feel themselves
subdued they wanted to restore
that when Barack Obama withdrew the last
American troops from Iraq they had an
opportunity to do so and the Islamic
State formed out of various Sunni groups
that were fighting against bash Bashar
Assad in Syria and against the Shiite
regime in Baghdad and the Islamic State
very quickly was able to gain control
over a territory larger than the size of
the United Kingdom and it's still
controls that today one of the first
things they did when they went into
mosul was knock on the doors of the
Christians homes and demand the gizia
the konic
tax and they painted the N the Arabic
letter the Arabic letter N for nazarine
which is the Christians the quran's term
for Christians on the doors of the
Christians so they would know this is a
house where the Christians live we have
to make sure to collect the tax from
them the Christians didn't want to pay
the tax they hadn't paid it remember it
was abolished in 1856 so not only had
they not paid it but their parents
hadn't paid it their grandparents hadn't
paid it their great-grandparents hadn't
paid it it was out of living
memory and here come these guys
demanding that it be paid because it's
in the
Quran and the Christians
refused
now that's why their lives were
forfeit once you refuse to obey once you
refuse to
submit then there's only another one one
other choice and that is you are
killed there's a a tradition a Hadith in
which Muhammad the prophet of Islam he
says when you meet the unbelievers
invite them to convert to Islam if they
refuse that invite them to pay the jiza
that is to submit and accept the second
class
status if they refuse both then fight
them if they refuse both then fight them
the Christians in mosul the Christians
in Iraq in general and in Syria they
refused to pay the tax they refused to
submit and so they were killed or they
were they were able to escape from the
area and Christian communities that had
been there for 1400 years are now
gone this was all based on the
reassertion of quranic principles and
Islamic
principles and it all comes down to that
idea that Jesus himself enunciated that
they kill you and they think they're
offering service to God God now that is
just one example of the inversion the
moral inversion that this represents
Isaiah said woe to those who call evil
good and good evil there is no group to
which that more that better applies than
the Islamic State
today and not only do they kill and
think that they're offering service to
God but they also proudly avow that they
love death and this is one more Quran
Passage in chap
62:6 it says oh you who are Jews if you
arrogantly claim that you are God's
chosen to the exclusion of others then
long for death if you are truthful if
you claim that you're God's chosen
people the Quran says to the Jews then
long for death now that's a very strange
thing to say and some people might say
well that just has to do with a will
willingness to be a martyr and that
might be all there is to it except there
are other indications that there's more
than that involved the Islamic jihadis
of the Islamic State and other groups
Al-Qaeda and others like them they have
many many times affirmed over the years
we will win because we love death more
than you love life we love death more
than you love life jart sarv the Boston
Marathon bomber when when he was
captured when he was almost captured he
was in that boat do you remember he fled
to a pleasure boat in the suburbs and
was hiding inside it and the police were
closing in and he found a Sharpie in the
boat and he started writing on the
inside of the boat and what he wrote one
of the things that he wrote was we look
into the barrels of your guns and we see
Paradise because we love
death
now loving
death is obviously the opposite of the
Christian Spirit and the idea of loving
life of God being the author of life and
we love life and we love creation and we
love the manifestations of the human
spirit that celebrate those things
another thing that the Islamic state has
done that you may have seen in the news
is destroy Priceless and irreplaceable
Assyrian artifacts 2,000 3,000 years old
that they came into control of and going
into the the museum in mosul and
smashing them to bits and you may have
read that this was uh to avoid idolatry
but nobody was really worshiping old
Assyrian winged horses and that's not
really what it was all
about chapter 3: 137 of the Quran says
go around the world and see what became
of the civilizations before you and that
means go around the world and look at
the ruins because the ruins are
testimony to the Judgment of Allah that
these these civilizations were
idolatrous and were unbelieving and
Allah punished them and destroyed them
and so and who how does Allah punish and
Destroy unbelievers by the hands of the
Believers so if Allah is punishing and
destroying the unbelievers by the hands
of the Believers and showing thereby his
power and the Quran commands you to go
around the world and look at the ruins
and see what became of the civilizations
that rejected Allah then there's another
Divine responsibility that the Muslims
have to create ruins to
destroy because that in itself shows the
power of Allah so you have a group like
the Islamic State that loves
death and that loves
destruction and that denies the
cross and denies the Redemption of
Christ and hates women you have probably
heard about I won't I'll spare you all
the revolting details but the sexual
slavery there's a very Illuminating
piece in all places the New York Times
today about the uh Islamic State's
practice of sexual slavery and how it's
based on the Quran and so much else that
shows that we are facing in that a
quintessential anti-life force a
quintessentially evil force a force that
is perhaps a more concentrated evil than
has ever before been encountered in
history and that's not excluding the
Nazis or the Communists although they
certainly rival it and
so the Islamic state has very often said
that it's coming down to the end it's
considers that it is preparing for the
Twilight battle the last struggle
between Good and Evil and they see
themselves as the good and even their
magazine is called davik which is a town
in Syria where in Islamic tradition
that's where the Armageddon battle
between the forces of good and the
forces of evil will take
place they see all this in those terms
and I believe that they've got a point
in that and that we need to see this in
those terms as well not necessarily not
to be presumptuous and say oh yes this
is the end of the world I think it's
always good to be cautious about
prophecies like that and applying them
to our own age but certainly that this
is a challenge to the church and to
Christians each individual Christian
such as never been seen
before and or at least has not been seen
since the very early Roman
persecutions and that we are called upon
now
to understand exactly what's at stake
and to know that the stakes are indeed
very high that this group and groups
like it are going to keep coming no
matter what and they're going to keep
advancing because they have an
imperative to rule the world in by their
own uh uh statements they're going to
keep advancing until they're
stopped and how and when they will be
stopped well a lot of that of course
will be a military thing but it's also a
spiritual
battle a spiritual battle requires
spiritual weapons it requires not only
prayer and fasting the two things that
the Lord said about the most virent
demons there this kind can only be
driven out by prayer and fasting but not
only that but also something that I
think is very much lacking in the west
today and that we each have a
responsibility to try to restore and
that is an understanding of an
appreciation for what judeo-christian
western civilization has brought to the
world students in schools nowadays in
Public Schools all over the country
you're I'm sure you're aware of this are
more often than not taught to be
embarrassed at being an American and
being embarrassed at being a Christian
or coming from a Christian background
and understanding that all that means is
racism and
oppression and these things coales very
nicely with the Islamic State's agenda
and with the agenda of Islamic
supremacism in general that a group that
does not appreciate what it is who they
are and what it has and what it has done
is not going to defend
itself and a group that cannot
understand the value of what it is
brought to the world doesn't even have
any desire to defend
itself and yet this is the
civilization that has brought we are the
children and Hees of the civilization
that is brought to the world Concepts
that we take for granted that we think
are as natural as breathing the freedom
of speech is the Cornerstone of a free
Society the concept of the equality of
dignity of all people before the law
that's a quintessentially Christian
concept stemming from the idea that we
are all created in God's image and
endowed with his
Spirit there is no other religion that
teaches that in the Quran 48:29 it says
Muhammad is the Apostle of Allah those
who follow him are merciful to one
another and ruthless to the unbelievers
and it says in chap 3: 110 to the
Muslims you are the best of people on
Earth the best of people whereas in
chapter 98 verse 6 it says of the
unbelievers the unbelievers among the
people of the book that is the Jews and
Christians who don't become Muslim are
the viest the most vile of created
beings now that's not the idea of the
equality of dignity of all people the
that from which comes the idea of the
equality of Rights of all people before
the law these things are foreign to
Islamic societies and there's a very
good reason for it they're not taught in
Islam and you add to that the
institutionalized discrimination against
the people of the book and you see even
more reason why these societies are so
stratified and do not have concepts of
universal
justice these things are our own
patrimony and it is very very important
it is there is nothing else more
important than that we impart
them with the faith and with an
understanding of History to our children
our children's children and help them to
see that there is a very big difference
contrary to the popular cliche today in
what whether you believe one thing or
another and it does matter what you
believe it does matter the content of
the assumptions that you bring to the
world and that the beliefs that come
from the Quran are beliefs that lead to
hatred and violence and oppression does
this mean that every every Muslim every
believer in the Quran is hateful and
violent and oppressive of course not if
you think about the Christians that you
know you know that there are some who
are very devout and very knowledgeable
and some who are
neither and every gradiation in between
and it's the same thing with Muslims if
the teaches something it doesn't
necessarily mean that any individual
Muslim has any knowledge of it or any
interest in it but that doesn't mean
it's not
there and that we need to understand
that it is there and that what is going
on in Iraq what's going on in Syria
what's going on in Indonesia in Pakistan
in Egypt and elsewhere where Christians
are being persecuted today it's not an
accident it's not a retaliation for
American foreign policy it's not a
response to depr ations uh real or
alleged of the United States or of the
state of Israel it is something that is
based very deeply as I've tried to show
briefly today on konic imperatives and
as such it's not going to go away as
long as there are believers in the Quran
there's not going to be any kind of
dialogue or negotiation or concession
that will change
it what we can what can change it of
course is the power of the truth
in so far as we ourselves have the
courage to stand upon that truth without
the slightest compromise and without the
slightest Demmer and without the
slightest hesitation in the face of what
are certain to be in the coming days and
months and years increasingly virulent
and even violent
challenges and so the good news is is
that we know how it ends up and we know
that we will win we know that life
always triumphs over death we know that
life will never be entirely extinguished
and that you know uh even in the Soviet
Union at the times when it was most
violent and oppressive Soulja nsen wrote
about how there were little movements
here and there what he called Blades of
grass through the concrete that showed
that the spirit of freedom and the
spirit of life and the true Spirit of
service and love for God will never be
extinguished from the human
Spirit but getting from here to there
it's not going to be a very easy ride
and there are hard times ahead and of
course uh we have abundant warnings
about that and abundant advice about how
to deal with it in this in in in
Christian scriptures and so that
ultimately is where we can find the
answers to this tremendous Challenge and
it is indeed a tremendous challenge we
have the best of all fighters on our
side in the Lord but we have to be
willing to stand for him no matter what
as he stands for us thank you very
[Music]
much Wonder than a small symbol of our
together call
please be seated our schedule calls for
a time of Q&A uh with uh Robert Spencer
and uh if you'd like to ask him uh some
questions uh that perhaps have Arisen as
a result of of what you've been hearing
please go to a microphone and uh we'll
we'll call on you and we'll allow him to
uh address your issue go
ahead Tom emry from Redeemer Lutheran in
aaso Michigan uh do Dr Spencer there
have been
persistent reform movements within
Christianity is there any such a concept
you think uh possible or likely within
Islam it's always possible i' never say
it's not possible but likely I think not
uh in Islam there is the idea that the
Quran was delivered in perfect form and
there is a passage where Allah says to
Muhammad this day I have perfected your
religion for you so if the religion is
perfect what what needs reforming
reformers also in a context in which the
penalty for apostasy and heresy is death
it's very hard to get a reform movement
going because the reformers keep getting
killed uh
it's you could say well you know
Christianity went through times like
that and it was because a kindly Prince
uh gave Martin Luther's shelter and so
on but there have not been any such in
Islam Mahmud Muhammad Taha was a
Sudanese reformer in
1985 and he taught that the peaceful
passages of the Quran should supersede
the violent ones and he was executed for
for heresy by the Sudanese government in
1985 aked Aid is a uh a lay spokesman in
Morocco nowadays and he taught the same
thing just recently uh earning him a
death fatwa from the Moroccan clerics
and he's now living in hiding so it's
very difficult to reform given those
circumstances anything is possible but
it's it's very unlikely and it's very
foolish of the western governments to be
putting their hope in that reform which
they're doing now yes yes sir
mik I can hear you just I'll repeat the
[Music]
questional
sweetheart of thewood and this book no
God but God says that according to
the that
Orthodox are not even considered to be
people
the so he says that
go that's comment on that the second
thing I'd like to know way
the recent war in
Iraq there were the estimate civilian
Muslim no one
really you think we all
know
problem you
think sit has what has what led to it
the war oh yes
okay politically Rel of War Empire sure
I I'll I'll take the second question
first in case you didn't hear it it was
about uh the war in Iraq and did I
believe that the war in Iraq and the
toppling of Saddam Hussein has
contributed to the current chaos and
there's no doubt about it yes certainly
this is obviously not the intention of
uh the United States in toppling Saddam
Hussein but it uh was I believe
ill-considered and the problem is is
that there are no good guys in that
battle Saddam Hussein was a vicious and
brutal dictator but without a vicious
and brutal dictator what you have in
Iraq are three former ottoman provinces
that all hate each other kurd Sunni
Kurds Sunni Arabs and Shiite Arabs and
there's no no Iraqi nationality it's
it's a fictional country like Yugoslavia
or Belgium that has no uh cohesion no no
natural cohesion either ethnically or
politically or religiously and so uh
without a strong man it's going to fly
apart and given the context you're going
to have Sunni Shiite strife and attempts
to impose Islamic law on the Christians
and that's exactly what we got I think
the Bush Administration and the Obama
administration because they both have
subscribed to these politically correct
fantasies about Islam being a religion
of peace they did not have any idea any
of this was going to happen thank you
very much uh but they should have uh the
first question Raza aan is a very
popular uh Muslim writer and uh
apologist who makes part of his uh makes
it part of his business to assure
non-muslims that Islam doesn't really
teach Warfare or hatred or uh any of
these things that we see committed in
its name all the time which only begs
the question of why is it that so many
Muslims are misunderstanding Islam in
such a severe Manner and all in the same
way uh but in any case I find the
question very strange because the
gentleman asked it said that in his book
no God but God which I admit I have not
read uh he says that the Byzantine
Christians were not even considered
people of the book does that mean they
were considered worse yes uh I don't
think that that's historically accurate
um the as a matter of fact if you read
going back to saphronia of Jerusalem who
was of course a Byzantine Christian in
the 7th Century who according to Legend
turned over the keys of Jerusalem to the
Calef Umar Umar lays out precisely the
regulations that the people of the book
have to follow for living under the
Islamic society and they are a constant
of Byzantine history after that point so
I think that that's uh if that's indeed
what Rea oan says it's a strange thing
for him to say since he's usually saying
everything is Rosy but it's it's it's
not inconsistent with his record to be
inaccurate um if you actually if you uh
if you look at uh my website Jihad watch
I have just a few days ago a whole long
catalog of his egregiously false
statements that he makes but he has the
right opinions and so he keeps making
more he gets Christianity wrong too but
thank you very much do thank you good
yes sir Jean Grim from Prescot Arizona
uh in light of this talk about the
religion of Peace would you say
something about the doctrine of
abrogation between the Mecca and Medina
texts sure uh chapter 2 ver 106 of the
Quran says when we agregate or cause to
be
forgotten a verse then we will give you
one that is good or
better we being God so he's saying if we
cancel out a part of the scripture we'll
give you something just as good so don't
worry about it now that obviously is a
passage that was invented by somebody
who's making it up as he goes along and
he's contradicting himself and then he
has to explain how is is how it is that
the immortal God is contradicting
himself and so he's canceling stuff out
it doesn't uh apply the uh Islamic
theology generally understands this to
mean that chronologically later passages
that were considered to have been
revealed later in Muhammad's career
cancel out ones that are earlier if
there's any contradiction the most uh
frequently cited example of this is
alcohol there's a passage in the Quran
that says don't come to prayers
drunk that's all don't come to prayers
drunk which implies that you can be
drinking just don't come to prayers
after you've been em bibing over
imbibing then there's a passage that
says there is some good in alcohol but
the bad out ways the good and so it's
getting worse and then there's the
passage that says alcohol is from Satan
so don't drink it
so this is considered to be a
progression easing the Muslims into the
idea of the prohibition the total
prohibition of alcohol okay that's fine
it's a little bit odd that it would say
that there's some good in it and then
that it's from Satan but we can leave
that
aside later on you have the problem of
the violent passages and the peaceful
ones in the beginning of Muhammad's
career According to Islamic tradition he
was a preacher of various religious
ideas he did not have any political or
military power and he taught tolerance
it was actually tolerance of himself he
wanted the Pagan Arab establishment of
Mecca to tolerate his
group when he moved to Medina later in
his career and became for the first time
a political and military leader then he
began to teach Warfare first defensive
Warfare and then offensive Warfare and
there are various passages regarding all
three in the Quran and the general idea
is the same that because the passages in
joining Warfare come later than the
passages in joining tolerance the
Warfare is valid for all
time and applies for all
time nowadays though you hear people you
hear Islamic spokesmen like R oan and
others say that Islam is a religion of
peace and they quote all these peaceful
passages from the
Quran what they don't tell you is is
that those very passages are considered
to have been AB ated in Islamic theology
by more violent
passages and they only apply when
Muslims are in a situation comparable to
the situation of the Muslims in Mecca so
when the Muslims are a small group that
is weak and has no political or military
power then they preach tolerance that's
the situation in the United States today
but as they grow they become more
aggressive and start preaching warfare
that's what we're seeing in Europe now
and it'll come here again
soon come here as well soon yes uh thank
you Mr Spencer for that uh I'm a little
bit ticked off because that was my
question um but I'm glad that you went
on that that line of answering because
now given the you know explanation
you've given concerning alcohol I'm so
glad I'm not a Muslim and a Lutheran
Canadian so uh so I'm going to have to
think of another question I have I
actually had two so I'm going to ask you
a more simpler one first in in Nazi
Germany there was a symbol that was used
for those who who were Jews and that
actually did not come from Nazi Germany
did it came from actually from Islam is
that not correct yes that's correct okay
it came from the kff mutwakil in the 9th
century who uh made the Jews and
Christians put symbols of devils over
the doors of their
houses and uh made them wear special
clothing and the Jews clothing was
yellow and the Christians was blue and
this was to mark them so that a Muslim
coming down the street would not say
assalamu alaykum peace be upon you to a
non-muslim because that's forbidden in
Islamic law in Islamic law you say you
you say if I see you if we're both
Muslims and I see you I say assalam
alayum peace be upon you and you
sayum or and also upon you not with you
upon you but if you see a non-muslim
coming you say peace be upon those who
are rightly guided that is peace be upon
the Muslims not on
you and so the K mut made the Christians
and Jews we to distinctive dress so that
they would not get the Islamic greeting
by mistake and so that they could be
marked very easily for the payment of
this tax and so on so if I can ask one
short question in place of the other one
that he stole from me um if could you
explain if your understanding at all
about the discovery of the first uh um
Quran in in Yemen and the implications
it has for uh for the Quran yeah you
know I guess you've heard about the uh
the the original or the the very early
copy of the Quran that was recently
discovered uh in Birmingham England
actually and it was uh carbon dated a
couple of pages of chapters 18 through
20 of the Quran and found to be dated
between uh
540 I think 5 550 to 575 to 650 and so
everybody was amazed because this would
obviously make it the one of the
earliest qurans and people were going on
in the BBC about how the person who
wrote this might have been taking
dictation from Muhammad himself and so
on Muhammad uh is supposed to have died
in 632 and the Quran collected in 653 so
if this is dated from 570 to 650 it's
it's very early but one thing that the
people who made a big deal about this
didn't notice or didn't pay any
attention to was that 570 date Muhammad
is supposed to have become a prophet in
the year 610 and died in the year 632
so if this document could have come from
between 570 and 610 it might not be the
Quran at all it might be some of the
bits that were taken to make up the
Quran yeah because the Quran itself
Bears very many signs I wrote a book
about this a few years ago did Muhammad
exist available at any self-respecting
bookstore and in
it in
it the Quran there very very many
strange things about the Quran but in it
it shows very many signs of heavy
editing and as a matter of fact there
was a re another recent manuscript
Discovery in tubingen in Germany that uh
was dated from in in the
670s and they published page after page
of it online and I was just amazed
looking at it because you see all these
places where stuff is erased and other
things written over it and I thought
this exactly confirms what we I and some
others have been contending that the
Quran is
a a a composite book made up of other
older material that was cobbled together
to create the holy book of this new
religion see uh if you look
historically there Muhammad is supposed
to have died in 632 and by the 69s the
Muslims rule from from Spain to
India and yet if you look in the
Contemporary records of that period
there is Nar a mention all the while the
Arabs are conquering everywhere nobody
no mentions these people came in with a
new prophet and a new holy book and a
new religion nobody mentions that can
you imagine these conquests were
supposed to be energized were supposed
to be inspired by Muhammad in the Quran
and in 60 years of those conquests
nobody mentions Muhammad or the Quran or
Islam and the people who are conquering
aren't even called Muslims by the people
who they conquer and who leave records
as to what happened sephron is of
Jerusalem who I mentioned before being
one of them he's supposed to have taken
Umar around the city and so on but in
his own writings he never mentions
Muslims he never mentions Umar he never
mentions that they came and said we have
a holy book we have a new Prophet none
of that he shows no sign that they are
anything like that and it what it seems
if you look historically is that
Muhammad is an invention like Robin Hood
maybe a historical figure but one on
whom a great deal of Legend has been
overlaid and the Quran is a is a is a
creation by committee to create a
religion and why is this religion
created because the Arabs conquered all
this all this land in those days you
didn't have constitutions you didn't
have parliaments you had a single
unifying religion the Byzantine Empire
was Christian the Persian Empire was
zoroastrian the religion unified the
empires the Arabs amassed this huge
Empire they needed a religion to hold it
together and they made that religion
Marshal and expansionist imperialist and
belligerent to make sure that those
virtues so to speak would be inculcated
into those into their people so as to
make sure the Empire would be continue
to be strong and expand and so anyway
this discovery of this supposed ancient
Quran actually only undermines even
further the standard Islamic story of
the origins of Islam yes sir last
question oh sorry um um yeah um Doug
dner Annapolis Area Lutheran Church
Anapolis Marland uh first of all I
grieve that people who speak the truth
like yourself have to have such heavy
guard surrounding them all the time it's
sad anyway my question is a point of
clarification you were talking about the
Christians of mosul living for 1400
years in relative peace and then that
changed was that because simply they
were not required to play to pay the
jizzel jiz the what what I meant was
this when they lived under the
caliphates the umaya the Abbasid and the
ottoman caliphates they did pay the
gizia and they were subdued they did
submit to Islam rule that's when they
lived in relative peace now it was
always a very very tenuous peace and
their lives could be forfeit in any
moment for a perceived infraction but it
wasn't the wholesale destruction that
you see today what happened is then the
abolition of the gizia the abolition of
the dimma in in
1856 is followed by a period in which
the Christians live almost as equals
with the Muslims in that area but when
the Islamic State comes in in and wants
to reassert Islamic law they demand the
gizia from the Christians the Christians
don't want to pay and so then they're
considered kufar hary infidels at war
with Islam and thus they have to be
killed and that's what's happening now
that's why these ancient communities are
being destroyed now I'm sorry about
those who uh yeah sorry I apologize I
shouldn't have been so longwinded but
anyway thank you very much
only